porque para ellos
Bueno hay otra cosa
[Música]
bueno a ver las informaciones y las
documentos y los preparativos están
dados para que se entreguen esos
permisos prácticamente en este momento
diríamos que eso es lo que falta para
continuar dando los pasos y lograr hacer
la traslocación de estos hipopótamos
[Música]
iniciamos el contacto con la India y con
México con
santuarios esto es decir con lugares
adecuados que tienen todas las
capacidades para el manejo de estos
hipopótamos y con ellos hemos venido
trabajando una propuesta para llevar 60
hipopótamos a la India y diez
hipopótamos a México
[Música]